hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to my name is mayo now when
I found insanity clicker I found this
game in the related games tab and it was
so bizarre that I have to play this is
the first time I've opened this up and I
imagine I need to click this damn jar of
mayo and something's gonna happen
hello oh yeah I got a new achievement I
don't know what that means you can see
the hits oh okay it's good oh I don't
know what of random fact number 25 then
the ender Thals brain was bigger than
yours is oh is that so that damn
neanderthal thinks he's better than me
huh I got another one okay random fact
number 50 the King of Hearts is only the
King without a moustache great wonderful
I'm doing the double clicking whoa I
didn't expect to get another one hello
red bikini girl how are you doing
sometimes I just like to wear my red
bikini it makes me sad Oh poop it makes
me feel confident
wow what went on in my brain that made
that poppin oh I have no idea that
probably reveals something about my
personality that I'm not sure is okay
Boing Boing Boing whoa I don't know what
that means but the achievement was named
young boy when I was a young kid select
this achievement to start story oh why
oh oh whoa whoa whoa the grundle on that
jar of mayo is not okay why why okay
this is the first time that I've
actually questioned why I'm tapping a
jar of mayo oh I'll tell you something
important about life
all right zu it
what about huh forget it what am i doing
okay the box of love what is I get the
box of love but that's not on here life
is like a box of chocolates oh okay
that's good to know
so do I need to woo aha
I got two achievements with that one see
gather round and I'll spin you a yarn
you won't believe but when I wear my
leopard bikini I feel like going wild
I'm getting a lot of mixed signals about
this jar mayonnaise sorry jarmail
another very different all right
oh that's adorable what is going on here
oh it's so weird
okay why I wanted to be a rock star when
I was a young kid okay alrighty then
let's spin a yarn oh it's literally yarn
ah I'm so continue to perfect ok Oh
random fact number 200 every year about
98% of the atoms in your body are
replaced oh boy I thought that was every
7 years yeah whoop [ __ ] alright it was a
stormy night and it was raining cats and
dogs oh great ok hit this hundred times
what keep wearing the leopard I don't
know about that
Oh ah this is like it's hitting me in
waves how absolutely ridiculous this
game is yeah oh no I took the top off oh
when I feel wild I do crazy things
oh oh oh my god oh look at that sexy ass
jar of mail okay I did what I could
I don't know if there's any more than
that I don't know how many achievements
era oh my god
who has the life to do all these holy
[ __ ] oh my god alright let me try one of
the other ones life is like a box of
chocolates ah just kidding just kidding
who compares life with a box of chocos I
don't know you know we have muscle
reflexes and all that stuff that's why
we moved uh okay oh boy more okay let's
get serious life is a part of our lives
as it's the day of our lives
oh Jesus what do you what you don't like
my philosophy on life
not particularly hey I'm the one talking
about life not you hey I talk about life
all the time you can god damn it let me
get a word in edgewise oh so you think
you could define life better than me
I'm mayonnaise
there we go oh I think that story might
be done how many times have I hit it I
have no idea I don't know if anything's
gonna help me just like Daddy
oh that's weird okay I wanted to be a
rockstar let's try that one
oh yeah play the guitar baby yeah whoa
dad what is that dead my dad wanted me
to be like him oh man you're looking so
manly happen to have it a habit out of
that
oh god I got Helen oh I got another one
after I got to clubbing ordinary let's
see an ordinary mayonnaise well Oh adds
more boring come on give me something a
bit more tap it wild and free hit this
ooh I think I know well I think I know
Oh back to the craziness yeah oh yeah
creme de la Vega creme de la May oh boy
I feel horny oh my god
we know this game about a jar of
mayonnaise would get so sexy oh hey is
it doing doink enjoy doing how you doing
ha ha ha
oh oh okay oh oh I should have known
that was gonna be pretty literal have it
have it have it so when is this gonna
stop oh ah I got another one Z Z Z the
day was over and I was ready to go catch
some Z's back home
wait oh come on now
don't be sassy with me game but then I
met a gorgeous blonde bombshell
alright whoa oh ah okay
alright I get it ha ha ha ha ha what did
I do
we rapped about sauce I hope it wasn't
too cheesy oh my god Oh aren't you just
the most clever son of a [ __ ] ever
I guess considering this as a jar man is
an inanimate object would be just as
sexy as a normal object but maybe this
jar man wants to put on its prog in Oh
slap that cheese I'm about to woo
cup of joe hundred-percent innuendo we
seemed to hit it off so I invited her
for some coffee if you catch my cold
does that mean Oh God
whoa what the hell this game is
ridiculous and I love it I love
everything about it
my clicking finger it's getting weak
whoa screwed Oh No
but I forgot my apartment was an armpit
so I was screwed what oh god oh god
man is an interesting perspective on the
male anatomy right here I hope that
screw isn't fastening this jar into
place in this lovely hairy armpit see
screw that yep this one takes some hits
we're on the pond that she's been
trained as soon as we went she flipped
in she flipped out and then totally
vanished Oh chief uh ah yes of course of
course of course that's the way it is do
I still need to click down this train
flipped yep five hundred hits holy [ __ ]
why am I doing this why aren't i
clicking this so many times
oh no oh I'm just in a Oh what does that
mean I felt pooped out the next day but
what do I know about love okay right Ian
oh man
why do I have to hit this ten thousand
times that's impossible
I'm not going to stick around with that
geez oh I need to click this some more
oh wow banana I have a secret I hide
from everybody it's like my fantasy not
whoa what the hell that is so weird
ah love the banana outfit it's doing
something for me I'm not sure one but
it's doing something whoa oh is that a
potato Oh someone call jacksepticeye vis
getting hot in here you're not into my
banana suits how about this well you
should know it's more is about to be
censured in Ireland holy [ __ ] yeah whoa
ah even better
I love okay that's not sexy maybe this
will cheer you up I don't know cats up
whoo-hoo it's still white slow confusing
do I still need to click I don't know
yep red mayonnaise hit 300 times red
ketchup is that what you want
No maybe hit this 500 times I don't know
if I could do that all right oh but
there's the same as before I thought we
did this already
maybe we just did the bottom half of
this but I don't know oh it's a leopard
on the cat zip that's okay I got you
know whoa elephant fun times I don't
know what that means but I like it I
don't know what you want
oh but that's not it Oh God jeez and
boink oh I thought there was gonna be
something to 4,000 oh boy
man Bob inevitable of Lola ah there we
go
Oh what hell happened identity issues so
I had some identity issues this is going
down the Train of the daddy one I
shouldn't call it oh hey oh my god oh oh
oh jeez
best deal best seller no no I don't want
to be a top seller mayonnaise like him
okay fine you don't have to be question
mark whoa
glam rock wow that's moving into a
different time period I just want to
play my guitar with glam style don't we
all
don't we all oh that's that's not a good
look for you that's no better than the
other look that you had before it's all
bad to be honest it's just all bad in
the end my dad supported me yeah
in the end though it's only 50 for this
one
whoa a mine oh but now I want to be a
mime why can't help you on that one I
don't know what you won oh geez
the only ones left are just getting
number of clicks and man my
and is brutal ah my arm is just tensing
up all the muscles in here just
exploding out of my forearm and man like
I need to work on my clicker strength
okay there's gonna be nuts since I have
to get to 10,000 and my arm is already
cramping up I downloaded an auto clicker
and ordinarily I wouldn't do this but I
want to see this to the end to see
what's gonna happen and I don't even
think I would be able to make it so here
we go ah [ __ ] god damn it go in fits and
bursts yeah yeah yeah this is gonna take
forever
all right now we're making progress ah
ah there we go
what's our new achievement habit habit
habit of random fact number 5,000 venus
is the only planet that rotates
clockwise that's interesting why is that
I'm gonna switch back to the bikini with
the elephant for some friggin reason I
have no idea why how we're approaching
on another achievement dude dude let's
go what do we get anyway now come on
little more huh whoa stop right on the
money
what do we got random fact number 8,000
the group of cows it's called a murder
well we all knew that it's not not
interesting way isn't there yeah that's
all okay few more I am going to coast
the last bit by hand cuz I believe that
auto clicker is way faster than I am
that did it in no time at all
boink whoops point point point point
point point Bank woo wait what happened
an ingredient to rule them on what do we
do now well I don't know what do we do
now random fact number 10,000 even if
you say you don't like mayonnaise it's
impossible that it's in some of your
favorite food oh it's possible okay uh
wait hang on was this Oh God raining
poops how did I have that geez yeah what
about this and then it's a mime okay
good but now this what do we got open
yourself to others just like you open
this jar of mayo well I guess if I
clicked it enough it would have happened
oh it's a life lesson to end the episode
yeah so thank you everybody so much for
watching this game was absolutely
ridiculous and I loved it for it so
thanks again if you want to play it I
mean not that there's much else to play
but I'll put a link in the description
below thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video oh you sassy sooo